مرحبا بكم في هذه النافذه الانسانيه
الخاصه بتداعيات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
في مختلف الصعد سينضم الينا في هذه
النافذه من القاهره ريتشارد برنن مدير
الطوارئ الاقليمي بمنظمه الصحه العالميه
وسنناقش مساله فتك الامراض المعديه بسكان
قطاع غزه نشير في البدايه الى ما اعلنته
وزاره الصحه في غزه من ان عدد الشهداء
ارتفع الى 24
1448 في حين بلغ عدد الجرحى منذ السابع من
اكتوبر الماضي
1504 واشارت الوزاره الى ان 70% من ضحايا
الحرب الاسرائيليه اطفال ونساء كما قال
المكتب الاعلامي الحكومي ان هناك 7000
مفقود تحت الانقاض او مصيرهم
مشهول من ابرز الامر امراض المعديه
المنتشره في قطاع غزه بين النازحين
الامراض التنفسيه ومنذ بدايه الحرب سجلت
480,000 حاله لامراض الجهاز التنفسي في
قطاع غزه
و1000 حاله اسهال بالقطاع و
26000 اصابه بمرض الجرب الادويه التي تم
تسلمها تكفي فقط ل 20% من الاحتياجات
الاوليه خصوصا الجرب وامراض الجهاز
التنفسي والاسهال نعود الى ضيفنا السيد
ريتشارد برانان من القاهره مدير الطوارئ
الاقليمي بمنظمه الصحه العالميه مرحبا بك
سيد ريتشارد برانان ماذا تقول لكم هذه
الارقام بشان الامراض وما تداعيات ما
يحصل تشير اليه هذه الارقام بانه ما زال
هناك مستوى كبير مستمر من العنف نتيجه ادى
الى اكثر من 20 الف قتيل
والاف الجرحى اضافه الى تدهور كبير جدا في
عمل المنظومه الصحيه والرعايه الصحيه
وكذلك الان لدينا حوالي 1.9 مليون
شخص نازحون قسريا يعيشون
في مخيم
مزدحمه غير صحيه ودون الحصول امكانيه
الحصول على الماء النظيف او الرعايه
الصحيه او النظافه النظيفه اذا هذا وضع
خطير جدا يزيد الى نسب الامراض التي يشرت
اليها مثل لسال وامراض تنفسيه والجرب
وامراض جلديه قويه اضافه الى تحديد الوصول
ابناء غزه الى للخدمات الصحيه الاساسيه
الاشخاص مضا بامراض مزمنه مثل ضغط الدم
العاليه او خفاق الكبد او النساء الحاملات
التي لديهم مشاكل في الحمل وايضا مرضى
اخرين قد يكون لم ظروف اعتياديه مثل
الزائده الدوديه او غيره كل
هؤلاء حصولهم على الخدمات الصحيه وانخفض
بشكل كبير معظم المستشفيات في غزه توقفت
وجزيء بسيط منها يعمل ويعمل جزئيا وفقط من
72 من العيادات ايضا تعمل بالتالي هذا
يعني الوضع في غايه الصعوبه وان
الاحتياجات الصحيه كبيره جدا ابقى معي سيد
برينان ينذر تراكم النفايات الطبيه في
محيط المستشفيات التي لا تزال تعمل في
قطاع غزه بكارثه صحيه كبرى فهذه النفايات
التي كانت تفرز وتعامل بعنايه طبيه قبل
الحرب تتكدس اليوم في الباحات والطرقات
بما تحمله من امراض وادوات حاده ومواد
كيميائيه تهدد الاطفال والمرضى والعاملين
في القطاع
الطبي ممكن ان تقع كارثه صحيه
وتلوث وقد وقد وقعت هذه الكارثه يعني بعض
الناس الان موجود لديها عده امراض احنا
بنعاني هالحين من مشكله حاده في اللي هي
النفيات الطبيه والنظافه في سواء كان داخل
الاقسام او خارج الاقسام ويرجع ذلك لعده
اسباب يعني انها اولا يعني عدم توفر
المعدات اللازمه وادوات النظافه على سبيل
المثال يعني ما فيش عنا الحين لا يتوفر
لدينا اللي هو قشطات مكانس مواد نظافه
صابون ايدي صابون الارضيات مطهر ارضيات
كلور ماء
نار كان في السابق يتم سرز النتيات من قبل
الكوادر الطبيه عننا كيس اسود للنفايات
العاجيه والكيس الاصفر لل نساي الموجيه
يتم نقل وجمع النساي في داخل الاقسام
نفسها منضم من حاويات كبيره ثم يتم النزول
بها الى مكب النفايات
وكانت كانت الامور تمشي على وثيره سليمه
لكن الامور اصبحت صعبه جدا لدرجه انه
احيانا ان الحاويات التي تتم والموجوده في
مركب النفات اصبحت تنقل في دا الاقسام
وهذا اكبر
خطا من جهه ثانيه اللي هو العدد الكبير من
المرضى والنازحين ففي المستشفى اليوم يعني
يزيد عن 30 ال بين مريض ونازح اضافه الى
وجود النازحين في مراكز
الاواء المجاوره للمستشفى حيث يترددون على
المستشفى للاستفاده من الخدمات وهذا يؤثر
على المخرجات وعلى النفايات وزياده
حجمها احنا عننا في اشكاليه كبيره انه عدم
توفر مواد ومعدات نظافه بسبب استيرادها من
الشمال للجنوب والقطع والطرق متقطعه
بنعاني كثير من الشيء هذا العمال بيقوم
يقومون تجميع النفايات من الاقسام الى
اماكن تجميع النفايات في الخلف
المستشفى طبعا هذا يشكل خطوره على بات
المرضى المنقص المناعه لان المرضى المنقص
المناعه سواء الاطفال او في مرضى عندهم
الامراض المزمنه مرضى السكر مرضى الضغط كل
هؤلاء مث نطلق عليهم كبار السن مرضى منقوص
المناعه لا يتحملوا مثل هذا
الوضع سيارات اللي هي ترحيل ال من
المستشفى الى المكاب يعني عدم انتظام
حضورهم بسبب اللي هو يعني اللي هو الحرب
الموجوده فاحيانا
يتعرض السائقين هؤلاء الشاحنات او العربات
المخصصه ترحين الفيات لاطلاق النار للقصف
وكذلك المكب نفسه تعرض للقصف هذا يؤدي انه
تاخر ترحيل
النفايات هناك طبعا مخاطر شديده وهي مخاطر
انتقال العدوى وذلك بسبب العبث من قبل
الاطفال في النفايات الطبيه الموجوده
والمتراكم في جميع انحاء المستشفى والتي
يمكن ان يؤدي الى امراض معديه تنتقل عن
طريق اللي هو الجروح او اما عن طريق
التلامس لهذه النفايات او عن طريق
الاستنشاق اضطرينا ان نتعامل بانفسنا
وبمتوسط ان نسيطر رغم وجود ازمات كثيره
لحتى اللحظه لم تحل لم تحل ونحن
حاول اعود اليك سيد ريتشرد برينان مدير
الطوارئ الاقليمي بمنظمه الصحه العالميه
يعني سيد ريتشرد اسرائيل تتوعد بان هذه
الحرب ستستمر كان هناك تفاهم بموجبه دخلت
بعض الادويه اليوم الى قطاع غزه
ولكن هذه الادويه لا تكفي سوى لاقل من 20%
من الاحتياجات الاوليه في حال استمر الوضع
على ما هو عليه ما هي مخاوفكم وما هي
السيناريوهات التي يمكن ان نكون
امامها نعم كما قلت ان الاحتياجات كبيره
جدا وهي في زياده مستمره وان وصولنا
لمساعده الناس
المحتاجين اصبح صعبه كثيرا في كثير من
الاوقات وبالتالي اعتقد ان عده امور
مطلوبه حاليا بشكل كبير اولا المنظومه
الصحيه لابد من ان تحصل على حمايه ان هناك
تجهيزات غير كافيه وهناك خطر على الرعايه
الصحيه وبالتالي لابد ان نحمي المنظومه
الصحيه من المزيد من الانهيار ولا بد ان
نعيد التاهيل الخدمات
الطبيه واننا بدانا بفعل ذلك في عده مثل
في مستشفى الشفاء بدانا بالقيام ب نقوم
هناك بعض عمليات الجراحيه التي كانت بعد
التوقف طبعا كما قلت نعم صحيح نحن لا نحصل
على ما يكفي المساعدات ونحتاج زياده كبيره
جدا في المساعدات
وبالتالي نحن بحاجه لمزيد امكانيه زياده
الوصول والمزيد من عبور الحدود ونحتاج
لمزيد من التمويل من المانحين الدوليين
وما ان نوصل بالمساعدات الطبيه لابد ان
يعطر حريه توزيعها على المستشفيات بطريقه
محميه ودون عوائق لانك الكثير من غياب
الامن ومن الصعب علينا احيانا
المساعدات في شاحنات الى مستشفيات في
الشمال ولا بد ان نستطيع اعاده تشغيل
المستشفيات
مستوصفات هذا يطلب حمايه ويطلب موظفين
ويطلب تجهيزات واضح و رح يطلب الامر وقف
اطلاق النار اشكرك من القاهره ريتشارد
بانن مدير الطوارئ الاقليمي بمنظمه الصحه
العالميه وبهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى ختام هذه
النافذه الانسانيه عوده الان الى غرفه
الاخبار لمتابعه اخر التطورات